For every, every day. They're always,
it's just finding out how to do
hard things is usually useful.
The model,
and it wasn't just the Higgs Boson
particle that you guys had discovered.
What is cork glue on plasma.
Yeah. So that, that's, um,
shortly after the billionth of
a second after the big banks,
you end up with a supervisor,
quarks and gluons quarks and the building
blocks of protons and neutrons and
gluons are the things
that stick them together.
And so a proton has to up quarks and down
Clark and an eagerness to down quarks
and up quark and so on, so that the
constituents, the protons and neutrons,
which of the constituents of
our atomic nuclei, um, savy go,
if you get to very high
temperatures are high energies,
then the protons and
neutrons faults a bits,
then you end up with a
soup of quarks and gluons.
And that's a quiet gluon plasma. And
it's insanely dense, right? Yeah. Well,
very high energy. So, um, so you get that.
So we've been exploring
that bite cause we don't,
we don't only collide protons
together. We can collide, uh,
lead nuclei together or Silver
Nuclei together at the LAC.
And that's when you make these kind of
soups of nuclear matter, if you like,
very hot and nuclear matter to explore
that physics, that nuclear physics.
Wow. And I was reading something
about the, the weight of,
of that stuff that like a sugar cube.
Like what,
what is the, what does the actual weight,
well, it depends. Our dense is that said,
don't they? I mean, they were,
the thing I remember is it the sugar cube
of a neutron star material, which is,
I don't know how many hundred million
tons. I can't really, you know, the,
it depends. So I don't know
where the quite Glen plasma,
I don't know what number you're,
there was something that was one
of the things after the discovery,
they were talking about the massive
weight of Cork gluon plasma and were like,
almost incomprehensible. Yeah.
Yeah. I don't know the number, but,
but something crazy. Yeah,
yeah, yeah. Now one, once these,
you got something, Oh, here
it is. 40 billion. Oh my God.
A cubic centimeter. Woodway
40 billion tons. Oh,
good Lord. I didn't know that.
I know David actually again.
Again. Yeah. The dentist matter
created in the big bang machine.
What are they doing right now?
It's um,
close for engineering and upgrades
and upgrades. Yeah. I mean,
one thing we're trying to do is,
one of the things in particle physics
is that you want as many collisions per
second as you can generate and then they,
we have a collision.
We have a, what's called a
bunch crossing LHC. We can vary,
but it's something like 25 nanoseconds
depending on what to say. It's really,
we get a lot of collisions per second and
the more collisions per second you can
get,
the more chance you have in make an
interest in things like Higgs particles or
whatever else may be out there
waiting to be discovered. I mean,
it's possible there are other particles
out there that we haven't yet discovered
that could be within the reach of the LHC.
And if this one that was in Texas had
gotten built and it was more powerful than
the, than the LHC, you'd have even more
opportunity to do something like that.
Yeah. Now when these things are
created by these collisions,
how long do they last?
Oh, fractions of a second.
So that the general rule in physics,
in particle physics is that they're,
the more massive it is and the
more things it can decay into,
the faster it'll do that.
So basically the,
the heavy things decay into light things.
And so the only,
the stable particles are
things like electrons. Um,
and some of the quarks, the quarks
and down quarks is stable things.
But uh, so, so everything
tends to decay very fast.
So we're talking fractioned
billions of a second fractions.
And how are they less than that?
How are they registering it's
existence? Like what is, uh,
what is being used to measure it?
So what you see if you collide the,
at Aaic, we collide protons together in
president's got loads of stuff in them,
loads, ugly ones and the quarks. So
you got a big mess, first of all.
So most of it's a load of particles or
spray. Now we should not interested in.
But sometimes when you,
when let's say a couple of the glue on
this bang together and they can make
something interesting like a top quark
or a Higgs particle, what's a top quark?
I saw quite, it's a very heavy, there's
six quarks. There's up and down chairman,
strange bottom and top
US harm and strange.
So strange was literally in the, was
it the fifties I, we discovered them.
Someone said that's really strange and
strange and you kind of farcical and so
that, yeah, so we have six quarks
and they're in three families.
So the up and down or one
family and then the chairman,
stranger and other family in the
top and bottom of the third family.
And so we for some reason,
so the only thing,
the only festivals we need to make up,
you and me are up quarks
down quarks and electrons.
But for some reason there are two further
copies of those which are identical in
every way except they're heavier.
So there's the charm and the strange
quark and if they're in a heavy electron
called a on and then as a the
tough and the bottom quark.
And another happy electron call the tail.
And that's it.
So that there's this weird pattern
that we don't understand. So we don't,
seems like you only needed the
first family to build a universe.
Right. But because some reason
there are two copies now signed.
The heavy ones decane to the lighter
ones is the point. So when you make them,
they're not around very long
as just answer your question.
What happens is that when they decay,
they throw their decay products
out into ad detector. So we,
we take a photograph of the cascade of
particles that comes from these heavier
particles decaying. And the trick
is to patch it all, look to see,
to try and work out where
everything came from. Wow.
Now when they five find
these unexpected particles,
then what happens? Then there's the
study of them. Then there's the, yeah,
and everybody gets together and go,
okay, what the hell is that? Yeah.
What is that and what do we do? So we
want to know where the Higgs particle,
we know what he does,
which is it gives mass to everything.
So it's fundamentally the thing that
gives mass to all the other things in the
universe at the most fundamental
level. So, so electrons for example,
and the up and down quarks.
And again I mass from their
interaction with the Higgs,
that's why they're massive. That's
another reason we exist. You know,
we go ray back and we wouldn't exist
if there wasn't mass in the universe.
And the Higgs is ultimately
responsible for that mass.
And I keep saying,
I keep caveat in it because then you get
other sorts of mass that are generated,
but, but that the fundamental
basic seed as it were,
is from is from the Higgs.
Um,
so what we want to know is we want to
know how that thing behaves and the way,
so you want to study it.
So you want to make a lot of them so
you can say a lot of pictures of it and
study a lot and say exactly how he does
that. And so that's what we're doing.
That's what we're
engaged in at the moment.
We're making high precision measurements
of the way that particle behaves so we
can understand the laws of nature.
I mean that that is the laws of nature.
How are those popsicles behaving
and what are they doing.